die sonne ist schief und die man konnte
sich bisher erklären dabei liegt die
betonung auf konnte denn jetzt ist
womöglich eine erklärung gefunden worden
der neunte planet warum eine schiefe
sonne der beweis für den neunten
planeten sein könnte jetzt in science
fiction herzlich willkommen
es ist eines der großen rätsel jeder
kennt das phänomen aber niemand machte
sich daran es zu klären
zitat das ist ein so tief verwurzeltes
mysterium und so schwer zu erklären dass
man einfach nicht darüber spricht sagt
planetenforscher michael braun vom
california institute of technology
caltech das tabuthema ist die sonne und
ihre drehachse ist 6 grad gegenüber dem
planetenbahnen des sonnensystems gekippt
und niemand weiß warum niemand michael
braun hat da eine idee was wäre wenn der
geheimnisvolle neunte planet nicht auf
der ebene der restlichen planeten um die
sonne kreist sondern seine bahn abweicht
genau eine solche bahn abweichung wäre
nämlich die erklärung für die gekippte
drehachse der sonne
demnach würde der neunte planet mit
einer masse von zehn bis zwanzig
erdmassen in einer 30 grad gekippten
umlaufbahn um die sonne kreisen jedes
mal wenn er der sonne war hat er so
einen kleinen schubs gegeben und sie
kippte so langsam
andersherum ist diese schieflage der
sonne ein weiterer beweis für den
neunten planeten es wird immer
wahrscheinlicher dass er existiert und
wir wissen immer genauer wo er ungefähr
sein müsste zitat das ist wirklich
erstaunlich klein erklärt jedes mal aufs
neue etwas am sonnensystem das lange
rätselhaft war das sagt co autor
konstantin batterien vom contact die
ergebnisse dieser forschungsarbeit die
bestätigen die theoretisch angenommenen
merkmale des planeten 925 erdmassen und
eine umlaufbahn um die sonne mit einem
radius von 250 astronomischen einheiten
ich bin auf jeden fall sehr gespannt auf
den tag an dem wir ihn finden und was
wäre dann noch alles über ihn erfahren
hier bei pixum will ich dann auf jeden
fall ganz ganz schnell ein video machen
auch wenn es morgens und 4 ist und wenn
er das und alle weiteren täglichen
videos hier nicht verpassen wollt dann
durch mehr genau hier mit einem klick
ein abo aufs auge und gebt mir einen auf
die glocke also bis dann bleibt dran